ils partirent tamil et par un soleil
moqueur revint épuisé après une épreuve
d'endurance de 30 minutes disputées à
ivry-sur-seine c'était une des
animations du gala de clôture des 30è
jeu du val de marne cette grande fête
sportive dans le slogan est ensemble
partageant le sport a compté en une
semaine quelques 130 mille participants
et pendant ce temps les enfants courent
encouragés par les parents mais
attention ce n'est pas du cinéma
30 minutes de course ç'a eu d'entente
walla je continue encore un pote tu vas
te coucher
j'arrête là à suivre aussi cette
compétition de perche féminin réunissant
pour l'essentiel des affects venue en
voisine de l'insep située à vincennes
parmi elles une perchiste qui monte
amandine homo 15 ans recommande de
france avec 4 mètres 06 deux fois cette
année mais je ne souhaite qu'à cette
relâche à la passion la prochaine
devrait bien les élus opposés
l'intérêt d'une journée comme celle-là
c'est que il ya une quantité de garçons
et de filles de tout jeune dans tout
jeune âge qui sont là et qui vont voir
des champions et là les vocations
naissent ils ont envie de faire la même
chose limité pour pour tous sports
passions ses jeux du val de marne ont de
nouveau un talent